tha voilà alors certainement vous allez
trouver dans quelques instants que j'ai
quelque chose de changer et oui j'ai un
nez rouge
je n'ai rien bu que je vous rassure
c'est parce que nous allons parler d'une
association
je trouve une très belle association
humanitaire qui s'appelle zygomatiques
c'est des clowns voilà ils sont en
plateau avec mois qui viennent divertir
les enfants malades bonjour à vous les
trois clowns bonsoir un pinot je
commence par les hommes ça ne se fait
pas ce n'est pas bien bonsoir qui
incarne en bus les bons soirs à orange
il nous j'ai bien prononcer je bien
descendu jeunes et bien descendu alors
je rappelle que l'association a été
fondée en février 99
elle est née autour d'un projet
humanitaire qui lui avait démarré deux
ans plus tôt en 97
avec 6 scouts de france n'ont parcouru
cinq pays d'europe à la rencontre
d'enfants malades
et puis depuis l'association continue
son chemin en france à la rencontre donc
dans les hôpitaux
et vous comptez 19 clown adhérents avant
de vous laisser la parole je suis très
bavard mais je vous promets d'y laisser
la parole devrait commencer par cette
phrase du jour parce que je la trouve
très belle
c'est le rire est le chemin le plus
direct entre deux personnes est une
phrase que j'ai tiré du dossier de
presse de l'association et je trouve
cette phrase très belle alors je les dis
vous êtes venus tous autour du cou et
vous l'avez pas autour d'une ia comment
qu'il l'avait votre au nez rouge
en quoi c'est important d'avoir d'avoir
ce nez rouge est ce que c'est symbolique
pour l'association qui me réponds bah
oui tout à fait ça fait partie du
costume en fait j'aime beaucoup voilà
dicté au nez ça fait on est un
personnage avec un nez différent des
autres et tout de suite ça mais quelque
chose un petit piment à l'entrée de la
visite
alors justement vous intervenez dans
différents établissement hospitalier des
yvelines et notamment au plus près de
nous je vais citer le centre pédiatrique
de plaisir de saint cyr ou encore de
de bullion combien d'enfants vous vous
croisez comme ça chaque année vous savez
alors pendant la saison 2011 2012 on est
allé jusqu'à plus de 550 enfin voilà
visiter et tout au long de l'année
régulièrement tous les week-ends on
visite en particules particulièrement
versailles et puis poissy et puis
pendant dé certaines périodes de l'année
on cela on rencontre plus les enfants de
billons nantes
et voilà mes potes embrouillé alors
comme vous quand vous à l'origine des
enfants mais c'est qu'il n'y a pas que
des enfants il ya du tout petit c'est
qu'à l'adolescence
voilà et quand vous voulez vous voulez
rencontrer ces enfants qui sont dans des
situations difficiles on s'en doute
puisqu'ils sont à l'hôpital et personne
n'a envie d'aller à l'hôpital
qu'est-ce qu'elles sont les premiers
mots que vous utilisez auquel elle a le
premier geste qui ne parlait pas qu'on
voulait rencontrer ces ses jeunes et ses
enfants je pensais plus une rencontre on
essaye de voir les approches et les
bulles qui permettent de faire à c'est
un peu un langage mais le langage vient
après c'est plus sentir ce qui se passe
parce qu'il ya dans la chambre réagir un
peu avec eux à l'ouverte l'un de l'autre
voilà d'observation et ensuite nous on a
des petits objets avec nous qui nous
permettent à près de mettre en scène des
choses en interaction avec eux on
observe aussi sur des magazines par
exemple qui paul jusqu'à il ya peu on
peut créer du jeu ce qu'ils ont avec eux
leurs doudous tout ça et dont vous créez
à l'univers à partir de tous ces objets
de leur quotidien
mais l'important dans ce que vous avez
dit tout à l'heure c'est le nez de clown
en fait ça qui relèguent leur enlève
toutes les barrières mais pour tout le
monde aussi bien pour les enfants que
pour les adultes les parents
voilà les parents qui sont là ça il ya
plus il ya plus de barrières dans la
mesure où on a le nez de clown
on perd son service et cinq mairies non
c'est pas le sérieux c'est que vous de
suite les jambes le cloud chaque ajout
sympathique et j'arrive tout de suite
avoue une barrière qui s'enlève tout de
suite la barrière qu'on peut avoir dans
la société de tous les jours sans relève
tout de suite et là on a un lien direct
avec les gens et aussi bien que ce soit
les parents que les grands parents parce
que souvent dans des grands parents qui
s'amuse avec nous
puisque les enfants je disais tout à
l'heure votre collègue et ça c'est
vraiment important et ça fait plaisir de
voir que d'un coup tout le monde revient
en enfance je trouve ça c'est ok tout le
monde s'amuse en fait il est connu
maintenant quand vous arrivez dans les
centres des neiges à migennes
infirmières ses fans de nous on a des
photos de nous dans les centres quand
vous allez y aller j'espère vous y allez
pas les photos de deux clowns
zygomatiques
c'est vrai que les équipes sont très
très content de nous recevoir
on a prévenu avant ils savent ils ont
prévenu aussi les enfants et les parents
qui sont là on va avoir la chance
d'avoir des clowns donc sites sacrés
déjà une petite ambiance avant qu'on
arrivait près de nous expliquer en
quelques instants comment vous justement
vous travaillez que ce personnel médical
et puis vous nous dire en quelques mots
chacun pourquoi vous avez souhaité faire
partie de cette association parce que je
sais pas les quelque chose de phase ii
facile d'aller vers les enfants mais
c'est pas aussi facile d'aller vers des
enfants malades il faut je présume
préparation quelque chose enfin vous
nous expliquerez tout ça on va faire une
petite pause on est allé dans l'est dans
les rues de saint quentin en yvelines
poser une petite question pour savoir
quelles activités pour soulager les
enfants malades
on écoute ce micro-trottoir l'enfant
trouve tout de suite après année des
comptes ça peut être sympa je connais
une dame qui compte
peut-être que ça l'ait distrairait s'ils
peuvent pas trop bouger de leur du
coloriage de la fin de ces des choses
simples ça dépend la maladie on
heureusement très bien qu'on les visites
avec un animal et des clowns qui sont
très utiles pour les enfants malades qui
les remettra en selle très bien et puis
peut-être les laisser jouer de temps en
temps mais pas trop avec des ordinateurs
du théâtre
fut pas des spectacles de marionnettes
ce genre de choses là on peut leur faire
oublier leur leur quotidien à l'hôpital
on les fait rire soit avec des clones
choix avec des gens qui passent de les
voir qui leur raconte des histoires
amusantes au qui joue avec eux on aider
les parents à l'aller visiter parce que
c'est pas toujours évident restait qu'à
l'hôpital je ne sais pas une vie et en
croire nos reins que le fait de sortir
même un cinéma mais voilà des activités
comme ça c'est sa rente pour voilà pour
oublier un petit peu le calvaire de
certains parents et certains enfants
l'idéal je pense qu'il ya pas forcément
un traitement particulier à avoir au
contraire à mon avis pour les considérer
comme des enfants classique ils ont
besoin d'utiliser et penser à autre
chose et avoir l'insouciante d'un enfant
classique qui sera pas malade
c'était à son je trouve ce que dit cette
dernière personne a dit il faut
conserver l'insouciance des enfants ce
sont d'abord des enfants avant d'être
des enfants malades c'est aussi comme ça
que vous les considérez que vous aller
vers eux quand on a eu tout ça tout à
l'heure votre calme et posé la question
mais vous avez pas peur quand vous
arrivez devant ce qu'ils ont ici là et
finalement on est tellement dans le fait
de vouloir leur faire plaisir qu'on
oublie carrément on les voit pas malade
fois les voit pas malade et on en a qui
sont vraiment je me rappelle un petit
garçon qui avait un oeil mais en rouge
énorme et au début il a eu peur voulait
pas voir les clowns et puis après on
peut plus sortir sachant pas ce qui nous
chanter les chansons il n'arrêtait pas
justement malgré tout pour aller voir
ses enfants et les considérer comme des
enfants et ce qu'ils sont d'ailleurs
vous ne pas voir la maladie est ce que
vous il ya une forme ainsi au trou suivi
des formations
alors oui mais il ya des formations donc
déjà on se retrouve
un samedi par moss blindés encore
maintenant c'est donc dans cette
formation on essaye de vraiment créer un
groupe m'intéresse c'est qu'on y verra
plusieurs à 3 ou 4 est déjà ça change
tout et donc on travaille
cette interaction entre nous le fait de
se connaître de pouvoir agir et mais
quand on arrive dans ce sens blindé avec
plus de sensibilité qui passe donc c'est
arrivé avec ce qu'on aille avec ce
qu'ils sont avec les parents est
vraiment à l'écouté justement vous dites
ce que vous êtes alors dans la vie vous
fait quoi
- vous êtes clowns professionnels non
chargé de communication de l'intérieur
dans des entreprises
gimont jean et mon t-shirt tous les
jours son petit sac à dos et vous moi je
suis musicienne
donc voilà vous êtes un coup de
musiciens quand même voilà amenez vos
instructions l'ennemi astros n'ont rien
à voir avec le clown je suis résoudre
cette technique donc si l'entreprise de
bâtiment bâti c'est bien lui le des fois
pour bennoo est vraiment comment vous
avez fait justement parce que vous venez
d'univers très différents comment vous
est fait pour vous vous retrouvez qu'est
ce qui vous a donné envie de participer
à l'association zygomatiques
moi par exemple je gilles bafa déjà donc
j'étais animatrice dans les centres
aérés donc je travaille beaucoup de les
enfants et puis j'aimais bien fait rire
et puis un jour pour nous il fallait que
j'aie un peu tous ces mots clés rire
enfantin dans cette association gère
trouvé vraiment ces éléments là et est
ensuite le costume idée théâtre que je
suis aussi à côté donc il y avait
vraiment ça se regroupent et moi je suis
musicienne et c'est vrai je trouve ça
bien de donner des concerts mais je
trouve que la musique se fait partie de
la vie et j'aime aussi les enfants et je
me dis que la musique elle doit aller
dans des endroits où elle est pas
forcément élue rire et le clown et
j'avais envie de tout mélanger donc
c'est comme ça que sur l'airé sociation
et vous alors qu'il travaille dans
m'étonnais beppino non en fait moi
j'avais je fais du théâtre aussi comme
mes autres collègues
en fait j'avais envie de pouvoir faire
profiter de tout ça aux autres et
d'avoir une action aussi humaine par
rapport à l'autre et le clown et au sein
de l'association de zygomatiques bon ben
c'est bien c'est ce qui est important
c'est qu'en plus dans l'association on a
vraiment de tout dans les professions
dieu est le meilleur souvenir pour vous
je pense que c'est quoi cette sourire
d'un enfant rien
ah oui de les faire sourire valait des
rires comme vous en voyez qu'ils sont
isolés dans une chambre depuis certains
jours parce que ils peuvent pas sortir
20 par rapport aux problèmes qui peuvent
avoir et que vous arrivez qui les a là
dans la charme qui vous appelle en nous
disant je peux avoir un petit chien et
pour redonner un petit chien il était
tout heureux d'avoir ça son père aurait
pu arriver avec la plus belle tablette
du marché
rien n'a rien arrive alors je résiste
pas la prochaine crise aidant merci en
tout cas vous 3 d'être venu en plateau
et donc c'est l'association zygomatiques
hélas quand vous êtes sur votre tournée
et nous aide de noël et donc vous allez
être très occupée ces prochaines
semaines autour des deux super en fin
d'année
merci merci beaucoup cette fuite est
terminé merci de votre attention
prochain rendez vous de l'information
locale ce sera demain à 18h en direct
l'émission vous sera présentée par où
les friedrich il sera notamment question
de la journée mondiale du bénévolat et
nous reviendrons aussi sur les 20 ans du
centre d'histoire contemporain de
l'université nous parlerons aussi de la
crise à l'ump en compagnie de jeunes ump
à très bientôt